ce mercredi vers 15h30 les garde côte en
voie des messages au bateau il est parti
de Libye d'y vouloir rejoindre l'Italie
et ne pas avoir besoin d'aide quelques
instants avant le drame alors qu'un
navire marchand envoyer des bouteilles
d'eau potable au bateau chargé de
migrants
ne vous jetez pas à 200 d'un seul côté
du bateau pour prendre des bouteilles
d'eau vous pourriez le renverser et le
faire couler quel est le principal
problème qu'on a sur l'immigration c'est
très peu un problème de principe c'est
un problème de capacité traitement de
données on a beaucoup de gens qui
arrivent on a des règles qui sont
anciennes et on les traite comme au
début du 20e siècle Frontex est un corps
de garde frontière alors que l'Union
européenne et la Commission considèrent
que fontex doit être une agence
d'accueil des migrants nous avons une
vision radicalement différente utilisons
l'intelligence artificielle et les
technologies pour traiter beaucoup plus
vite les données il y aura beaucoup
moins de fraudes on embauchera beaucoup
moins de gens et on ira beaucoup plus
vite mais dans la nuit qui vers 1h40 le
navire annonce un arrêt du moteur 2h04
le bateau chavir 10 à 15 minutes plus
tard le bateau coule complètement il
faut sévir contre tous ces gens qui
partent avec des bateaux qui ne peuvent
pas être en mer qui prennent des gens de
l'argent et qui les amènent en Europe
l'Union européenne doit redoubler
d'efforts dans ce domaine nous ne
pouvons plus nous permettre de perdre
des vies en mer
je vais essayer de pousser on l'a bien
entendu poussé sous entendu pour que
Kylian Mbappé reste au PSG ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'Emmanuel Macron
s'immis dans les coulisses du football
croyez pas que les Français ont assez de
difficultés aujourd'hui pour que le
Président de la République leur consacre
l'intégralité de son énergie
plutôt que de se mêler de ce qui ne le
regarde pas objectivement à mon objectif
était de continuer au club de rester au
Paris Saint-Germain c'est ma seule ma
seule option pour le moment donc
les murs des maisons sur le pas des
portes et même sur les routes
[Musique]
oh mon Dieu on les entend craquer sous
les roues
la liste de ceux qui ont été ministres
et déjà beaucoup plus longue de ceux qui
sont actuellement ministres et puis
alors si vous cumulez les deux listes
vous êtes heureux un chiffre largement
vert à tous ceux qui aspirent à être
ministre donc ne jouerons pas assez
pronostics là le phénomène est mondial
est frappe plus violemment encore la
région qui va de la Corne de l'Afrique
jusqu'au Pakistan dans le nord de
l'Afghanistan ou aucune pluie n'est
tombée depuis mars des millions de
criquets pèlerins ont attaqué les
cultures de ces paysans quitter le métro
à tout prix malgré le danger dans la
pénombre des tunnels enfile indienne ces
passagers tentes de rejoindre la station
la plus proche après 45 minutes
d'attente à plusieurs il force la porte
du métro et marche le long des voies
était à 10 mètres du quai et du coup on
s'est dit bon là en fait il y a des
escaliers c'est sécurisé on va sortir de
nous-mêmes les transports c'est la clé
pour un bon accueil c'est vrai dans nos
aéroports c'est vrai dans le grand
transport catholique la RATP la SNCF je
fais toutes les six semaines une réunion
de chantier très précise sur tous ces
sujets la ligne 14 l'investissement sur
le réseau de transports publics on
avance bien donnez moi juste une réponse
non non mais c'est ce que je suis en
train de faire en étant le plus détaillé
même si ça vous embête parce que je
pense que le l'heure du déjeuner est
proche etc et vous avez oublié
ce n'est qu'à 21h30 que l'ensemble des
passagers a pu être évacué l'incident
serait dû à une avarie sur un train
selon la RATP Marlène Schiappa
n'écoutable d'aucun détournement de fond
c'est totalement absurde elle se défend
très mal lui aussi on a vu de toutes les
couleurs à toute vitesse l'Américain max
Park a diffusé sur sa chaîne Youtube son
exploit au Rubik's Cube lors d'une
compétition en Californie ce génie du
casse-tête a battu le record de vitesse
de résolution en 3 secondes et 13
centièmes elle n'est pas calibrée pour
mener ce combat contre l'islamisme elle
n'a pas les épaules pour mener ce combat
contre l'islamisme doit être mené par
des gens qui ont de la consistance et du
courage
ou qui communiquent comme une simple
influenceuse sur Tik Tok